So why don't we walk through our solution here. First we
initialize this variable m, which we say is equal to length
of values. So we're basically saying here hey, this is how
many data points we have. We also initialize this variable called
cost history, which is going to track how our cost function
evolves over our iterations. We say for i in range num
iterations, which basically says hey we're going to update theta in
the costs. And number of times equal to the number of iterations.
Let's calculate the predicted values. We'll do that by taking
the dot product of the features and theta. Then we're
going to update our values of theta. This looks pretty
complicated, but you'll note that it's the same as the
equation that we just discussed, which we'll pull up again
here. So, we subtract our observed values from our predicted
values, take the dot product of this vector with the
features, and then essentially multiply by this alpha over m
feature and subtract that from theta. This is effectively gradient
descent in action, so we're taking a very small step
in the direction of the steepest gradient. Then we're going
to use another function called compute_cost which we see up
here. So you compute the cost function given our features,
our values and our theta. Then we'll append the newest
cost to the cost history list. And once we've done
this a number of times equal to the number of iterations,
we'll not only return our final set of thetas,
but also the entire cost history. You'll see that if
we run this function, we get this array, which
are theta values. About 45 minus 9 and 13, and
these values kind of indicate how significant each factor
is in determining our predicted value. So this 45 corresponds
to a constant term, the minus 9 corresponds to
height and the 13 and change corresponds to the weight.
And then we see here how the cost function has evolved
over time. Ideally, if we had a perfect model, this cost function
would approach zero. You'll see that our cost function doesn't, you
know, get close to zero. It, it does decrease a good amount
as we train this model, but it doesn't do super well.
And so this might lead you logically to a natural question. Which
is, hey you know not all models are created equal. Maybe
our model is actually bad. Is there some way we can evaluate
our models? Why don't we discuss this a little bit more?